[Music]
all right hello everyone can everyone
hear me okay and the back perfect okay
well yeah I'm Zack I'm a software
developer and data scientist at Pebble
go and what I'll be talking to you about
is what has been my pet project for the
past couple of months working on some
weekends and the project specifically
was building a robot that would
automatically film rugby matches and so
in this talk I'm going to be talking
specifically about some of the problems
that I solve to overcome this but the
more general points of the talk will be
about how you can do certain things
whilst you're building a machine
learning model to make it more efficient
to run on low-power devices things like
physical computing low-power devices
like Arduino Raspberry Pi so to start
off with I'd be able to define how many
people raise your hand if you've heard
of or work with physical computing
perfect I've got a slide for that so
physical computing always is any sort of
system that you have which doesn't use
keyboard mouse and monitor as the inputs
and outputs instead you use more
tangible inputs so these can be just
buttons sensors cameras that sensor
there's let's say a sonar sensor that
you find on the back of cars to help
parking those sort of things and the
inputs could be simple inputs or outputs
LEDs motors huge toaster things like
that literally anything and if you had
those as the inputs or outputs of your
systems you can sort of say it's a
physical computing system so if you were
to Google physical computing projects
online what you'd find is the majority
of them use one of these platforms so
you got Arduino and Raspberry Pi so sure
those really ring a bell with some
people so all these are are they're just
small low-power computers they're very
cheap they're less than about 20 pounds
but what makes them really good is they
have these pins here so you've got these
sharp ones and these sort of these are
female ones and these are male ones and
what's really
these are called general purpose input
and output or GPIO and on the code level
you have incredibly granular control
over these so you can specifically tell
one to turn on tell one to turn off tell
one to read a signal and that's what
allows you to connect them to virtually
any device you can think of so these are
really good for connecting devices but
because they're cheap because they're
well used they tend to be low power so
the Arduino is about 16 megahertz so
miniscule you can't really do much real
number crunching with it the Raspberry
Pi is a bit more beefier it's about the
same power as your run-of-the-mill
smartphone so you could potentially do
more number crunching with it and that's
what I talk about further is how we can
do these complex specifically machine
vision problems on the Raspberry Pi so
speaking on machine vision on machine
learning machine learning when there's a
lot of projects online that use machine
learning and these devices and the sort
of common pattern that they follow is
they'll build the machine learning model
and then just pass them off onto like a
webserver and let the device act as kind
of like a dumb terminal to just send
simple web requests to the web server so
the web server does all the heavy number
crunching and the low power device just
as the collecting of the data and
feeding inputs and outputs that's sort
of the standard practice however this I
think this is a sort of under use of of
the technology because what you'll see
here like here is just a tiny lastly
places the size of them and here's like
a battery pack used to charge your phone
so it's literally the case of plugging
one in and then it's not completely
wireless and not splitting up into the
Wi-Fi and stuff so these are incredibly
portable devices so what I plan to do
with this project is to sort of demolish
this model and bring them all onto the
Raspberry Pi therefore making it
incredibly portable so these sort of
things could then be implemented on like
bicycles you don't need to have
connection to the Wi-Fi so that's what
I'll be talking about about the problem
I solve so on to the problem
specifically it's kind of a grassroots
problem so back home and Northern
Ireland
rugby's pretty much the only sport you
play if you don't play rugby you don't
play sport and initially I was in the
latter category I would
watch I was more interested in video
editing and stuff so what I would do is
I would just film the matches and then
take them home and edit them into
highlight reels and montages of music
and stuff people loved it and this
worked great until I wanted to play as
well and I still want to record the
matches so what I do is I give the
camera to someone else and we wouldn't
have a professional cameraman lying
about so it would probably be like a
substitute on the side and they wouldn't
care as much as me about filming so the
footage would wouldn't be the best it
would be this is an extreme example it's
not fair to them they didn't try hard
most of the time but they in the extreme
cases you'll get this or footage so in
both cases the footage would end up
being shaky in the extreme cases you
would just miss the match completely but
in both cases that required a human to
hold the camera and focus on the on film
in it so I figured it requires a human
so let's see if I can automate it so
plan was I would build a robot that
would sit at the halfway point of the
pitch so sit there and a lot of the
times when I describes people they seem
to think that it it will run up and down
the side of the pitch but so it's solve
a simple problem it's just going to stay
there it's not going to move and there
are already systems out there that do
this sort of automatic filming but they
require you to wear like a tag on your
ankle and people don't like it when you
ask them to do that so I wanted to
system be completely passive so to
collect the actual input data it would
be a nice wide angle camera that just
filmed everything and then that's going
to be the input day that feeds into the
model and then I have that control a
proper camera that's attached to like a
motor servo that would then hopefully
with a well trained model will follow
the action and hopefully work so those
fellas go see a plan and through this
I'm going to show you how built that up
to your working prototype so the things
I used to actually build it it was just
it was one camera Raspberry Pi and a
servo motor it's basically a motor
except for the fact that you can
specifically tell it what angle to point
at so those kind of things are used in
like RC planes and stuff
but the common thing between all these
is that these are all cheap materials
like all of this stuff will be about a
lot of 30 pounds if you know where to
look
well actually just eBay is where to look
so it's about 30 pounds altogether and
what I'm doing specifically is because
this this is a cheap computer it can't
run number-crunching by intense number
crunching and for this problem
specifically it's machine vision and
real time so what I'm going to be doing
that now is to sort of show you the full
process of building a model that is
lightweight enough to solve this kind of
complex problem but fast enough to run
on a Raspberry Pi so the model is built
the sort of approach to building the
model standard approach initially was to
collect the data build the model then as
an addition build the robot this seemed
like a good plan except for the fact
that the data that I was going to use
for the mall didn't exist out there I
couldn't mine it from somewhere I would
have to collect the data myself and to
collect this data I would have to
collect it as I would use it in the file
system so the data would have to come
through the robot so all through the
plan filing and to build the robot first
then collect the data then I can train
the model so it didn't there wasn't too
much of a hassle but it just met I was
kind of investing myself into the
problem quite strongly from the get-go
so the robot design I'm just going to
whiz through this it's kind of out of
scope from PI data but I'm just going to
say have a tripod some sort of plastic
body the camera the PI kalamatas mug
there these fisheye lens which is going
to make it capture everything servo on
top and specifically on top of the servo
it's going to be a generic camera mount
so like you just mount any camcorder so
effectively instead of building a robot
that records I'm just building a robot
that points so why are applications I
guess for that and then on top of that
the camcorder any camcorder so the
actual rod is going to with you is put
on my 3d printing hat design some stuff
three printed at all I've got this is it
right here
so it's itchiness case and then you've
got the servo on this this is the servo
bit and then the platform on top is
where the camera goes on top so it's
just that it's not the nice looking
thing like it didn't get designed by it
anyone really it was sort of designed
just pure functionality so moving on now
that I've got the robot I can collect
the data so what's really great about
using a Raspberry Pi for doing these
sort of things is that ratifies so
widely is that the libraries they're for
communicating with most of like the
hardware that you're interested in using
so for the PI camera there's literally
alive we called PI camera and the line
create the camera object and then I
wrote a really simple function which
just takes the current time as a string
of the milliseconds and then captures
the image and then save the image as the
filename being the kind of those
captured so I end up with a big folder
after I run it of all the images with
the filename the time that the images
were captured so this is what the data
looks like so it kind of looks like
they've ever seen 2001 Space Odyssey so
the house you if he was into rugby and
for all the data eclectic elect about
six thousand images over the course of
two matches at a rate of about three fps
so that was that was all the data which
is great very excited all that worked
then change the sort of dark side of
collecting your own data which means
that if you collect your own data you
have to label your own data so if you've
ever had to collect your own data set
this is the bit you don't look forward
to so because it's incredibly repetitive
incredibly boring but this is incredibly
important because the quality of the
data will affect the quality of the
model and in this case and scenario I
know I'm going to be using a neural
network so the better quality data a
queued feed into it means the more
aggressively I can try to shrink down
that neural network and the slower
neural network the faster it will run on
the Raspberry Pi so collecting this data
and collecting it well and labeling it
well is incredibly important for this
application so usually when I'm labeling
data is for previous projects I would
just boot up into like a spreadsheet app
go through it line by line label the
data it's boring but it has to be done
but in this specific case I'm labeling
an image data so this will really be
convenient because what I'll probably
have to do is
have the images on front of the image
viewer how the spreadsheet in a
different window look at the image then
go over to the spreadsheet so I want to
label them like this so if the left hand
side is 0 the right hand side is 1
I want to label them where the action is
happening in that scene so I'm going to
have to look at the image guess where it
is then switch the next image guess
where it is type it in really key is
really boring and because it's so
tedious it opens the room for a lot of
error to be introduced into labeling or
data and terrorist data I want I don't
want that a lot really cleanly data so I
figured I could solve this problem
well not solve it completely I could
help it by building a little gooey so
this was actually the first time I
realized that I could build a GUI in
Python so Python actually has a GUI
library built into it called teach enter
it's kind of like if you've worked with
windows forms which boldly no one has
but it's really simple you say here's a
button and run events on buttons so I
built a little GUI to help me so I'll
run this hopefully you can sort of see
them by smoothing so what this GUI built
does is choosing image I can move the
mouse and it shows a line as to where
the mouse is and every time I click it
saves the image name along with where I
clicked on the image and I added in some
extra features like by right-click it
will set the image to null which was I
there was actually an important feature
because when I started filming and
collecting data would you place a camera
at the side of a rugby pitch that
automatically is taking pictures people
will mess with it that's just as rugby
players for you so messing anything so
there's other images of people bending
over towards the camera so I had to
introduce this feature and I also added
in extra features to lammeter using the
arrow keys go back see the labels adjust
the labels things like that and a one
more extra feature was even though I did
make this and it was made it a lot
easier it was still a bit boring so I
added in a feature that when I close the
app and I have reopened it it would drop
me off at the next image I needed to
label so I could label a couple hundred
get bored close it down open it label
the next couple hundred so that helped
massively so now I
got really good accurate labels and
that's going to help future when I'm
training the model and pruning the model
with it with the good data so that was
the data labeling next now that I got
the data label I can do something really
fun which is the feature engineering
part so for this this is the this is the
visualization of the data but keep in
mind that in Python this axis data
exists as a numpy matrix specifically
it's the width of the image by the
height and then three frames for the RG
and B so it's I think it's 480 by 640 by
3 so that's that's the way the data
looks in Python so the question is
looking at the visualization as a human
can I solve the problem with this
information and could I solve it with
less information so it's the question of
could I solve it with less data or could
I could I reduce the amount of data but
keep the information and if you look you
see it captured all the width which I'm
interested in there's also captured
loads of height it's captured flame
planes by flying past I like maybe if
there's a cat a cat scuttled past it
captures all that stuff which I don't
really care about so because it's nobody
I can do just a simple index split or a
splice reduce all that and then the
question is can I still solve the
problem and if I can then the mole can
still solve the problem and after I do
this it's 1/5 of the pixel to process it
doesn't it doesn't that doesn't
technically main speeds up the system by
5 just means 5 1/5 of the work for the
system to do so continuing on with the
feature engineering this amount of data
this is a 100 by 6 40 by 3 is still a
lot to feed into a neural network but if
you consider one frame of this
information and you show it to like a
baby and tell it where the action is
happening it doesn't know what these
colors mean it doesn't know what these
blotches are so to train a model on this
would still take a fairly complicated
model so there's a little trick you can
do in machine vision to isolate movement
that's pretty simple so always you can
imagine an image is the way the image
looks turned ugly so we've got tree and
stuff with the numbers and you've got a
frame that's different what you can do
is because these are just numpy matrices
you
- one from the other and all the pixels
that are the same value will cancel each
other out in the final frame so you end
up with just a frame of the things that
moved so you can do this this is how you
isolate movements and to do this in
number its the treat of that what the
frame - the other frame and then I add
in this threshold value so cameras have
a natural sort of noise about them so if
you do this with with a normal image
you'll get a lot of like pixelated noise
everywhere because the camera's not
going to take the exact same image so I
add in a threshold value to make sure
I'm only capturing the images where the
pixels that have changed by a lot so I
just choose an arbitrary value which
gives me at least enough focus on the
bits that change a lot so after I do
this I do that and then the threshold by
arises so it sets the ones that have
changed enough to one and the ones that
haven't changed enough to zero and we
end up with image live like this so this
is it I hope you agree is is that sort
of taking out the important bits of the
image so it's keeping the information
but reducing the data so this is the
this is not I'm on a good track so if
you show this to a baby and if you can
explain to the baby to look at the
interesting parts of the image it should
you would think that ok well this this
is the only bit I can see so I'll just
look at that so you can see the
simplification of the data so looking at
the if we look at the original image
it's 100 by 640 by 3 we calculate that
like I call a delta image is just a
difference of friends so reduced it by 3
and then there's actually another thing
we can do to this data so there's still
information which we don't care about so
I the camera I'm only interested in
turning it along the horizontal plane
what we're capturing vertical data is
wellness and I don't really care about
that I don't care if a person's like at
the bottom of the frame or the top of
the frame so I can just eliminate that
and so what I can do is I can just along
each column each pixel I'll just sum up
the total number and this this is
nothing save today again you can just
sum up along that axis and so we reduce
this down to just a vector of just the
information that we care about and we
can do the same the same sort of rule of
thumb which is as a human now that I can
see all the data
I still solve the problem and hopefully
you can sort of see now where the
actions movie notes are a lot less than
having a color image yes it is
yeah but then when you consider the the
end problem of just filming the
interesting stuff if a person gets in
front of the camera that's going to
capture it anyway so but then if it yeah
it's true if it is biased except this
hopefully if a neural network is trained
properly it will know to ignore that
bias because if it sees movement
happening in specific direction the
capture set was there's a good point it
can be biased people being close to the
camera but hopefully in the future I'll
help to alleviate that bias good point
yes so now that I've got the data moving
on to the neural networks so I'm just
gonna whiz through this because there's
more for about the implementation but
the neural network I used was the MLP
regressor so the regression because I'm
predicting a continuous value from 0 to
1 the MLP because I believed it would be
a sort of nonlinear problem so I did I
did do the hyper parameter optimization
and testing and pruning and try and
define the smallest possible neural
network that would give me a good bang
for buck performance and I ended up with
a structure which would have 20 input
nodes 1 hidden node at 33 or one hidden
layer that were 33 hidden nodes and one
output node and this actually gave me an
r-squared to a point 8 so the keep in
mind an r-squared sort of one is like a
perfect solution so point eight for this
for building the prototype was good
enough for me so I was ready to move on
with that so a visualization of this
sort of performance that it's getting so
here is a plot the orange values are
where it's supposed to be predicting the
blue values are where it's actually
predicting the along the bottom is time
and along the top is where it should be
looking so at the bottom it's looking to
the most left of the image carpets
looking to the most right so here a lot
of action happened on the right a lot of
action happened on the left
probably a trial scored here so as you
can see hopefully visually that they
match up decently
the bitter it's a bit off for this
specific problem is actually not too
much of a problem because the way the
camera captures it doesn't capture
exactly one point of capture is quite at
a nice slight angle so if it's slightly
off hopefully the action is actually
still captured so I don't mind that it's
slightly off at some points so that was
the mole I was happy with that no time
now comes the time just wrap it up and
bundle it into the Raspberry Pi
so what's Hadley is that I'm sure a few
of you are familiar with pickling which
is just taking a taking a PI sin
variable and persisting it or saving it
to a file so you can reanimate it later
so SK Turin has a nice little wrapper
around the standard pickle library to
make it even easier so I can just put my
model give it a name it's going to dump
it as a pickle file I can just copy and
paste that over to the Raspberry Pi
because the Raspberry Pi is just what I
have mine is running Linux so it's the
Trinity case I can even bring a USB
stick plug it in copy it over or I can
SSH into it and copy it over but it's
just a case of copying the files over
and then loading them and it's just as
easy with the with the library to just
load in the model and so now that I've
got the model the next case was actually
using the model in the Raspberry Pi so
this is where I land on the final trick
of getting this sort of thing to work so
the initial solution involved writing a
program which would first capture the
image then using the model to predict
where what was actually where the action
was happening and then move the server
and then this would just run in like a
while loop so I did this and it would
move the server except for the fact that
if you were to run it like this for the
system you want to capture as many
predictions per second as possible if
you capture only one prediction per
second there's going to be a second of
time where something else could happen
on the other side of the page so you
want to have a nice tight loop around
getting predictions and moving the
server so to do that it meant that for
this structure I could just spend a very
small amount of time moving the server
specifically just one execution and when
you do that what's going to happen is
the servo is going to come along and
then when I move the servo it's going to
be really quick to one side and then
something else happens
really quick to the other side which
doesn't solve one of the initial
problems that I want to solve which was
reducing the shakiness of cameras so
this didn't work what I could do to
solve this is spend a bit more time on
moving the servo so I could have wrote a
little loop run that servo to slowly
increment it across but like I said this
will affect the latency of actually
getting predictions so yes one execution
does not make smooth so if you want to
use multiple you can smooth it out so
one powerful trick in Python is you can
use multi processing so don't let anyone
tell you that you can't do multi
processing and Python because there is a
way to do it so what I can do is I can
capture the image predict the action run
that in its own process and then over in
the server will have it in its own
process as well and so between them
what's going to happen is the image is
going to capture it's going to predict
the action and then it's going to update
a shared variable and then it's going to
keep doing that it doesn't care about
anything else all the cares about is
getting predictions and updating that
shared variable and then move the servo
mover is the same thing it doesn't care
about anything else all it's carrying
what is reading this shared variable and
updating the position so it's free to
take as long as it wants to move that
servo nice and smoothly
so what Sally if you've ever done a bit
of web development
you probably heard of like easing
functions so I can there's also Python
libraries for that for each just copying
in an easing function so I can adding
this nice smooth movement to the camera
so this is all good in a visualization
but the actual code is surprisingly
simple so there is a library already
built into Python for this called multi
processing and import processing value
and when you start your script you
declare your shared variable and then I
declare the process for one of the
process so this specific one is the
process for camera tracking so in my
code I have a function that defines the
camera tracking code and in that is just
a while loop doing the capturing and
predicting capturing billeting caption
predicting and then I pass it the shared
variable at this stage and in my
function the function takes in a
variable so all it's doing is updating
that variable so we do that we create a
process
process then we create a process for the
server exact same way it serves just a
little function that has a while loop in
it it just going right updating a server
update a server and in each of these
functions they're manipulating the
shared variable just by calling the
share variable name value and that's how
you use the share variable the camera
tracking code updates that value just by
seeing it to equal something like that
and then the server process just reads
that value and it it works so just it
just works beautifully that code final
bit of implementation is now that I've
got the script on the Raspberry Pi the
Raspberry Pi is just running look so as
soon as I turn it on it's going to boot
up into Linux sit on the command line
and wait for you to do something so on
the side of a rugby pitch it's not
really convenient to bring keyboard
mouse and monitors to set up this script
so what you can do there's a nice little
trick is to there's this file that
exists on Linux and all that file has is
all the command line commands that get
run as soon as it logs in so you can
open it up in the Nano text editor and
just add in the line of code that you
want to run as soon as it turns on so
for this it's just running this script
here so this is the script to collect
the images so I add that to the bottom
of that file save it every time I plug
in the Raspberry Pi it boots up without
any sort of user input and begins
running that script so that's a really
handy tip if you're building these sort
of things so finally after I've done all
that I've got the robot it's finished
it's sitting there
ignore the cable management I'm much
more stringent at work with cable
management than in these sort of
projects so that's the ASCII image of it
so I wouldn't wouldn't be right to show
you it we like some video so here's a
video of it actually in action
so hopefully you can see rugby happening
and it turning towards the rugby so
that's all great but this highlights a
sort of issue the problem is that the
that still exists so what I would have
loved to have done it's just showing you
this footage alongside the footage that
it actually recorded however the system
cannot help you if you forget to press
record on that camera a future feature
may be some sort of sign or sticker but
currently
press record on that footage footage
that I did remember to press record on
was this specific incident now
the eagle I earn money among you may
have noticed I've got this nice bit of
NHS jewelry so if you look closely a
press place a couple of times so it's
rugby rugby here I come here I come and
then I lay down and have a little cry
and then what you see is the robot is
still focused on me even though it's
movement happening everywhere pardon
exactly I feel I'm thinking potentially
the model could feel empathy for me or
detect pain all these things possible
fun yeah exactly I don't know what it
was but potentially it shows in the
future I could build a model that
detects injuries pain its owner things
like these all future possibilities so
that's one is it so I like to show you
just a full match being played obviously
sped up I'm happy to make you watch the
film at your ugly so this is it this is
actually the first there's still a first
prototype so I'm quite just that it
managed to perform this well and a super
interesting point is that all this this
this match specifically is being played
on a different pitch from the pitch I
collected the data for us to train it so
that goes to show that the bits I did to
abstract the important information
seemed to work so not it is just caring
about movement and blotches of movement
so that goes to show that is it does
worked and it does work on across
multiple pitches you can see it still it
still lags behind some points but for
the most part first prototype it's
something I'm going to work on and
hopefully going to be better in the
future so final point is just to
reiterate that physical feeling is
pretty cool and the feelings are with
machine learning and I think it's sort
of underused at the moment I think we
should more try to think about embedding
machine learning into these remote
applications because you can just build
pretty cool stuff with it finally just
like to say thank you for listening
thank you for pie data
thank you for Marcos
until they and help me prepare for this
and yeah thank you so we have time for
the questions
Oh so see if they could predict the next
where the next bit of action is
happening yeah I was thinking like
that's like a future saying I was
thinking dancer yeah we'll do a thing to
look out for um yes yeah yeah just it
was a fulfilling the prototype I chose
the first thing that worked so I didn't
look I heard it was on my mind but
googling this is the first results but I
seem to work quite well so yeah
the moment the current system I think
it's it's predicting at about like two
frames a second so that's the sort of
reaction time that it has yes
so I profile the code to see the actual
speed of it oh no not at the moment
that's future thing too because I will
be continued to work on this so in the
future thing I'll be looking more into
analyzing the true performance that it's
how much is utilizing the Raspberry Pi
but yeah refine module three because
like I'm assuming the game lots of or
tomorrow yeah it's the pregnant so are
you relying on are you doing anything to
uh the current system I don't really
consider battery performance at all
I use these battery packs that you get
for charger phones because they plug
into a USB C and the Raspberry Pi is USB
C arts and this one shows the indicator
of how much power is in it after I
record a match it's also powering a
servo motor and it doesn't even go down
one bar so there are all low-power
devices so it safely covers a match and
you could cover a full week of matches
on just this oh yeah oh yeah the code on
github so you can follow it a bit messy
at the moment I'm going to be cleaning
it up but yeah the codes all there it's
all open source it's going to say open
source yeah yes oh yeah it was a bit the
angle yeah I I haven't tested to see how
sensitive it is I do take care to try to
get as level as possible I can imagine
the way I train the data as long as the
main bit of action is happening within
that window it's fine because I sum it
all up
so I'm guessing any certain is going to
be a certain point where if it gets too
far it should it should freak out of it
but as long as generally capturing that
in that sliced window it should be fine
yes yes in the future I'll work on the
cable management for for training the
model are I was just doing normal sort
of grid search of the hyper parameters
of the neural network so just testing
out things like iterating over the
neural net size and plotting out the
performance and just picking one that
was the best bang for buck to try to
minimize the size we know that when I
did that for the other things like
learning rate and what does it
regularization so yeah okay that is a
future a future feature that I like to
look into doing potentially even even
having multiple cameras because
techniques I have one camera will end
long term at the other the position they
predict we're also allowing perfectly
triangulate where it's happening and
then you could pass our data back to him
to zoom in accordingly so yeah that
would be a future feature like looking
doing okay okay yeah
no I hope you can see the motivation in
the one well yeah the predictions can be
quite a bit right
oh passing it back in like a sort of
like a recursive normal I would give it
the previous value
I'll just reduce the output oh like it
like a momentum on the output yeah I
should look at it now yeah I could do
that yeah that's true
yeah but look into doing that cool oh no
I haven't it's many been rugby but
that's just I like how much more worthy
cause but yeah definitely yeah I think I
hope that'll be fine
because on the emotions on a release
which are usually quite simple because
everyone moves in the same way like if
someone if someone breaks the line
that's the only fast object moving in
that direction so I hope for this system
is going to remain a sort of simple
problem but potentially if I'm building
a more advanced model that's going to be
able to pick out specific people they
could be using that but for my several
years case I hope it's going to remain
as simple as responsible all right
[Applause]
[Music]